there's only
uh
seven books
on page one
i don't want you to read these books
today
and i don't want you to read these books
while you're in iot
i want you to read these books after you
finish iit because it will be focused
first goal end why
second goal
keep good gpa get good internships get
the career launched
after career launch weekend reading
okay so these seven books
will help you uh answer the two
questions
either which manager
or how do i learn how to invest
how do i learn how to invest
is a 50-year journey ram there is still
learning
i am still learning
it's a beautiful experience to keep
learning so with that
[Music]
you